hello and thank you for joining us today
my name is Joshua and on behalf of
sundar we'd like to welcome you to the
second in a series of three webinars
jointly produced by Google and Intel the
goal of these webinars is teaching more
about our collective outtie efforts
during the broadcast if you have any
questions please type them into the chat
window we'll get to those questions at
the end of the webinar until then please
enjoy the proceedings hello my name is
Joshua Chong cloud architect and program
manager into Google cloud partner
engineering team welcome to the second
in a three-part webinar series and I'm
Martyn Kronberg Technical Evangelist
with Intel so in the previous webinar we
learned how to take all the data
generated by our Gateway and set it up
to GCP and in this webinar we're gonna
show you guys how to make that data
useful by the end of this talk we will
have answered the following questions
first how can we make all this data
coming in from our devices useful now
how do I manage these devices at scale
and lastly how can GCP make it easy for
me to set up my own global high speed
data ingestion service to answer these
questions
we're going to take your data on a
journey and the map of the journey looks
like this what you see here is a series
of Google cloud services each with its
own role to play this pipeline takes
your data from point A to point B in the
previous webinar we learn how to use
thing until nuke send data into Google
Cloud IOT core that data ends up into
pub/sub q from the pub sub q will use a
cloud dataflow pipeline to take that
data from the queue into a durable
storage service called
bigquery and from bigquery will
visualize that data using cloud data
studio to create wonderful dashboard for
your users but before we dive in let me
throw it back tomorrow to talk about the
hardware setup sure so I just wanna take
a quick look again at how the sensor
data is actually getting into GCP so for
this demo we're using the sensor data
that's coming from our gateway here and
we have our gateway attached to an
Arduino 101 which we're using as a
sensor hub
attached to this hub are three
environmental sensors temperature light
and sound in order to read the sensor
data we're using the Umrah and upm
libraries from Intel we can use a really
simple high level API to connect to the
sensor hub and then read out our values
from the sensors if you want to learn
more about these libraries and how you
can use them please refer back to the
first webinar of this series so Josh do
you wanna tell us a little more about
that data journey absolutely before you
begin I like to take a minute just to
explain a little bit about our global
network now this is important because
your devices could be deployed all over
the world and this has implications on
how your devices communicate back to the
cloud what you're seeing here is a map
of our global network you'll notice
you'll we have over a hundred peering
locations what this means is that most
likely will have a presence in the
country where your advice are deployed
into this also means that with a single
global IP address you could send all
your data to that simple
single IP address and Google will
automatically low balance out traffic
for you so data can come in - are the
closest pop or point of presence ride
our backbone and into the services in -
in the specific region that service was
set up in -
let's talk about the first service to
explore on our journey and this is
pub/sub or globally distributed highly
scaled messaging service when data is
sent to Google Cloud IOT it ends up in a
puff subtopic multiple subscribers can
subscribe to these topics and retrieve
information
it's a durable service meaning we will
retain unacknowledged messages for up
seven days it's a global service as well
meaning you can write to a single URL or
IP address and Google will handle the
low balancing for you couple with either
data flow or cloud functions pub/sub is
your on-ramp to real-time streaming into
the cloud
let me demonstrate how easy it is to set
up your own topic I'll also set up a
simple subscription so what you see here
is the google cloud pub/sub user
interface to get there on your DCP
landing page you would simply click on
the hamburger menu and select pub/sub to
create a topic you would select create a
topic and then define your own topic in
this case let's just call it demo click
on create and just that easy
you've created a topic but doesn't
really do anything useful until you can
create a subscription to create a
subscription subscription simply go into
the demo topic that you just created and
then click on create subscription in
this case we'll just call it demo and
there you have it you have your first
topic and subscription duo so let's do
something useful with this now we've
been sending data from the endpoint here
into pub/sub let's see what that looks
like
okay and in this case I will issue the
simple g-cloud command to pull data from
that subscription or to an existing
subscription I have that receive the
data from the endpoint and there you go
this is the data being sent from the
sensors to the note2 through iot-cloud
through pumps up and there you have it
in the subscription
you know Josh you talked about scaling
up your gate infrastructure using the
global GCP network and as you scale up
the cloud in the backend you're also
gonna want to scale up your harbor
deployments in order to gather more
sensor data be able to enact any
commands that you want to send down so
as you do this having a gateway is going
to be key
so the Gateway acts as a central hub for
all the sensors and actuators in a local
area you can send it the data gathered
from any number of sensors using any
kind of interface for instance if you're
scaling out to a factory that has a lot
of legacy sensors by which I mean
sensors that do not have a way of
connecting to the cloud themselves
you're going to need a device that can't
connect to the cloud and act as a data
collection and communication hub so
until has Gateway solutions that can
interface with sensors over the local
area network or using a serial
connection like Modbus for canvas or
short-range radios like Bluetooth ZigBee
or z-wave as well as many more
connection types so by having a single
connection point to the cloud you're
gonna inherently increase the security
of your of your deployment you look at
possible points of intrusion they're
gonna limit the number of certificates
you have to manage and you can use the
Gateway to set up a firewall that only
allows certain protocols through using
an IP table overall is going to be much
more secure than trying to manage a
multitude of connections you can also
run some data pre-processing at the
Gateway before shipping it to the cloud
from basic things like taking an average
over time to much more complex data
transformations and I'm gonna come back
to this point a little bit later on with
a few examples finally as a scale of
your data increases you're going to want
to also make sure that it's consistent
so consistent data is going to be easier
to parse as well as to manage and the
game we can also package up that data
for consistent cloud ingestion so in our
case and in many cloud connection news
cases we're using JSON to send the data
back and forth so this data transport
method is easy for humans to read and
it's easy for machines to parse
it's also quickly becoming a standard
for IOT data transport so you'll be able
to interface with many different
services using the same data pipeline
another aspect of scaling out your
project is scaling out the scope of what
the project itself can do so in order to
help developers really expand the
capabilities of their projects we have a
so called path to product at Intel what
the path the product provides is code
samples proof of concepts as well as
market research into specific verticals
in the IOT space including smart home
transportation autonomous driving so on
it's all open source and it's all up on
github under MIT licensing so you can
use what you need from our code Josh do
you want to tell us a little bit more
about what the data can do in bigquery
absolutely so bigquery is my favorite
GCP product now in the journey you'll
see that we're gonna skip over data flow
and we'll get back to that in a second
you'll see why for now let's talk about
bigquery bigquery is Google's analytics
database that's bilf a petabyte scale
it's ideal fret and analytics use cases
because you don't have to worry about
deploying more resources when you're
constantly pumping in more IOT data from
these devices it's fully managed no ops
data warehouse is built for petabytes
calls mention it but it's super fast at
the same time you get the convenience of
SQL so if you're used to writing SQL
you'll be able to work with bigquery
easily and finally it's an externalize
version of Google Dremel which is a
database we've been using internally for
over a decade so it's been hardened it's
been tested and it's been put in
production for well over ten years now
so let me demonstrate how easy it is to
setup your own database and issue some
simple commands so with the first thing
you'll notice is that you will you're
using SQL constructs here so you're
gonna select star from this table order
by ascending order click on run creator
is gonna run the query and notice how
fast it was this table has over 7,000
rows let's try it in descending order we
run the same query to see the data
change a bit and there you go right so
it's gonna sort this in descending or
notice how superfast it was do you
create a table again click on this down
arrow super fast where to create a
dataset we're gonna call it demo click
on OK and from the day of demo you can
create a new table save and you can
either create from source or create an
empty table let's just create an empty
table and call it demo table
keep that in mind we'll get back to that
in a little bit and just add a couple
fields
let's try timestamp which is an integer
and this fri temperature which is a
float here so i'm gonna click on create
table and there you have it your first
bigquery table
now that we have data coming into
pub/sub and we have a place to store
that data how do we get that data from
the pub sub topic into bigquery there
are a few options but today we'll focus
on cloud dataflow if you are familiar
with Apache Beam then you'll feel right
at home with cloud dataflow cloud
dataflow is a fully managed service for
transforming and enriching data in
stream or real time or in batch
historical with equal reliability and
expressiveness
so no more complex workarounds or
compromises needed at a higher level
you define a source which we call
inbound data and a sink out bomb data
when you bring data in it becomes a
collection in which a pipeline of
operations which we call transforms can
be performed the data source can be
batch or it can be streamed and there is
a time windowing concept which are lost
from great extensibility you do all of
this under a single programming model
which reduces complexity before we go to
a demo go throwback tomorrow to talk a
little bit more about ETL sure so
there's going to be three main parts of
data handling that the Gateway does for
us
the extraction transformation and
loading of data or ETL as it's referred
to in data science we discussed the
extraction of data or gathering the
sensor data we talked about the loading
of data or ingesting it into Google
cloud platform now I want to talk a
little bit more about the transformation
of the data so raw data is gonna be a
little rough there's gonna be outliers
there's gonna be some noise and there's
gonna be a time series of data that
follow certain trends when we're dealing
with a massive amount of data as a large
scale industrial deployment will we want
to be able to clean that data up as fast
as possible so to facilitate this
process in Todd's developed a set of
libraries called the data analytics
acceleration libraries or dahl these
libraries cover a vast amount of data
transformation methods linear regression
outlier detection and low order moments
or things like means sums
standard deviations so these are just a
few of the core tools that a data
scientist can use to transform raw data
and all these tools and many more are
provided by the doll library
and using that you can transform your
raw data into something more usable they
they can then be fed into our cloud
analytics pipeline so these libraries
have been optimized to run out until
architecture in order to provide an
extremely fast way to transform large
amounts of data and the best part is
that Dahl runs on Hadoop SPARC R and
MATLAB so that means that you can use
the data processing pipeline with which
you are most familiar with if you want
to try out these libraries for yourself
go to software TOCOM slash intel - da al
to download the libraries read about how
to use them and try them out now that we
have the ETL performing on the Intel
device itself we can still use dataflow
to transport the data from pub/sub topic
into bigquery let's see how to get to
date cloud dataflow you click on the
hamburger menu click on data flow in
order to have a number of services
already running this particular pipeline
is running to take the data from this
device from the topic and into bigquery
to create a new pipeline I simply create
a job from template now this really is a
template here because we don't have to
do anything sophisticated here because
the the nuke here is going to handle the
ETL I give this a name I'm going to use
the third option which is cloud pops up
to bigquery now just select this option
I'm gonna select two more I need to
provide two more pieces of detail one is
the actual topic since I have a pop
subtopic already open here I'm gonna
select this topic
and from Vickrey I'm gonna select this
table now you know why we skipped over
cloud dataflow and went directly to big
crate so so now that we have a big
creative table defined you can click on
run job and there you go that's your
first cloud dataflow pipeline taking
data from a pub sub topic and into
bigquery at this point we've covered a
lot of ground so let's quickly review
what we've done thus far on our data
journey we started out with the central
information coming to cloud IOT 4 from
there the data got into a puffed-up
topic just now we created a pipeline to
take that data from the topic and into
bigquery
now with the data in bigquery we can
move on to the last step which is using
cloud data studio which is a free tool
that allows you to make beautiful charts
from your streaming data instead of me
talking let me walk you through a simple
example to get to data studio you simply
go to data studio Google comm to start
click on the big blue plus button to
start a new dashboard the first step
when you create a dashboard is to create
your first data source in this case I'm
going to create one from my GCP project
you click on this big blue button and
you'll notice that data studio offers a
number of data connectors this makes it
easy to connect your data sources in
this case we're gonna use bigquery
because I've logged in with my GCP
account and knows which projects I am
and I have access to in this case we
will be connecting with to the Intel
webinar project as appropriate click on
edge data and here's that demo bigquery
table we've created but here's edge data
data table and I'm gonna click on
connect and connect this data source
which we'll notice here is that I didn't
encode up anything what data studio did
was looked into that big tree table
found the columns and automatically
created these metrics for me well smart
enough to identify that light was a
number of styles and number temperatures
a number even the timestamp which is
specified as an integer in bigquery it
was identified as a date which is
correct
here I'm gonna change a few parameters
around I'm gonna make these averages
instead of sums and let's add a bit more
detail to the time here and to include
both the day and the hour just make it a
bit more interesting I'm gonna add that
to the report okay here's your first
dashboard let's create a table that just
takes the raw data and dumps it to the
screen to do so I click on this table
icon draw up the table in the dashboard
and you'll notice immediately the time
stamps are already populated here it
added like but we could add a couple
other metrics and that's add sound and
lastly let's add temperature and there
you go so now you have a data dump of
the information coming in from the
sensor let's create a chart now to make
it a bit more attractive so I'm gonna
start with this time series chart it's
essentially a line chart now drag into
the dashboard now you notice that on the
x-axis it'll automatically populate it
with the timestamp by default it's
adding the light but we could add the
sound and let's also add the temperature
and there you have it in about five
minutes we created a beautiful table
with all your data and a chart then
gives it a bit more meaning than just a
list of wrote raw numbers yeah so this
visualization looks really great and
obviously that you can easily share it
with other people on your team that's
right to do so
you just click on this sharing icon and
list your teammates that you want to
share it with that's it great I mean
this looks really good and I can
definitely see how developers can use it
to start pulling out business logic from
their data before we sign off I just
wanted to circle back and discuss a
little bit more about advanced analytics
they can do on the Intel base gateways
so the type of data that we're able to
visualize here and really in almost all
cloud based frameworks is limited to
what you can send by a JSON so numbers
like floats are integers and strings of
characters this works great for many
date applications our demo here uses
sensor data which
encoded as an integer value between 0
and 10 23 which is a pretty standard way
of doing analog to digital conversion
but what if the data that you're
gathering can't be encoded into a number
or string so for instance more and more
applications are based around gathering
video or images and the only way to send
an image with a JSON would be to break
it up into an array of pixel values and
this can be both lumber some and very
bandwidth intensive so what you need to
do then is some kind of advanced
analytics at the edge before we get some
that data up to the cloud so Ansel
provides a whole host of tools for just
that with the Intel system studio this
is an IDE for C++ that integrates a
whole host of libraries and SDKs which
are created by Intel and meant for
advanced analytics check out
software.com slash system - studio to
learn more download the IDE and to start
using it and applying it to your project
one of the tools that's included in this
package is the computer vision SDK so
this SDK was released into public beta
about a month or so back and integrates
a bunch of really useful tools for
computer vision applications it's based
around open CV which is an open source
project for a computer vision originally
developed at Intel back in 2000 it's
grown quite a bit since then thanks to
an extremely active developer community
the CVS DK expands on the capabilities
of open CV by adding in optimizers deep
learning a visual algorithm designer and
a lot more tools and of course it's been
optimized to run on Intel CPUs so what
does this mean in terms of our data flow
well it means I just end up sending up
an entire image you can analyze it with
the CBS DK on the Gateway and then send
a data format that's easy for our
pipeline to ingest and then this way you
can expand the kinds of data they can
use in your application
that's all we have for today we hope
that today's session shows that with the
combined power of Intel's hardware
platforms with Google Cloud you too can
build a highly scalable reliable data
pipeline and please stay tuned for our
next webinar in which we're going to
demonstrate how you can use this data to
build your own machine learning
solutions thanks guys
you
you
welcome back we hope you enjoyed the
presentation and thank you for your
questions we've gathered a number of
questions that we hope we can answer to
start off let's start with number one
year
howdy charge for bigquery now there are
three dimensions to bigquery pricing
the first one is storage the second one
is streaming and the third is the query
on the storage side we charge about two
cents per brigid gigabyte per month on
the Streamy side we only charge the cent
for 200 megabytes per month and on the
query side it's $5 per terabyte of
querying with the first hair by being
free now data coming into bigquery and
data coming out of bigquery is free so
if you have any questions there's more
information on the website under
bigquery in the Google cloud platform
website number two another bigquery
related question you only showed BIC
we're using a UI is that the only way to
interface with Vickery the answer is no
there's multiple ways the first way is
through our REST API is very well known
what REST API is the second way is do or
g-cloud command line interface the third
way and I would say the most popular way
people are interfacing with bigquery is
to our native API so we do have API is
built for Python dotnet and Java so as a
developer you have options and how you
want to leverage your create into your
project here's the question on sensor
libraries so the question is how do I
learn more about sensor libraries used
on the Intel device so Intel actually
maintains a website called u PM m ra a
io it has all the information about the
sensor libraries the api's which sensors
you could use this site was recently
revamped so you should be able to access
all this information yeah it should be
easily accessible again the website is
upm dot MRA a dot io great Thank You
sundar
number four how much does data studio
cost there's a theme here developers are
concerned about cost the good news about
data studio is that it's a free product
as the date of this recording and it'll
it's currently in beta it's a free
product however
I do want to inform our developer
community out there that if you're using
bigquery as the data store to serve the
data into daily estudio you will be
charged for the currying and the storage
of that bigquery data so watch that but
the product itself today is a free
product cool let's see okay all right
great number number five another data
studio related question it's a great
question aside from the built-in data
connectors are there third-party
connectors available for data student
the answer is yes if you google data
suited community connectors you'll get a
result the first result will be a page
where we allow and educate developers to
create their own data studio connectors
so if the standard built-in connectors
don't do it for you you can kind of you
build your own and you use a product
called act Apps Script which is not
beyond the scope of this webinar but
it's pretty easy to pick up as well as
tons of information online in addition
to that community page we actually have
a gallery as well from third parties who
have already created these connectors
that gallery is linked off this
community page so again search for data
studio community connectors excellent
here's a question on device security so
are there any specific tools that help
increase device security actually there
are in fact very recently at the IOT
World Congress we announced a specific
feature called a secure device
onboarding take a look at it it's more
information is available with our wwn
Telkom slash secure device onboarding
with features like secure device
onboarding you can actually onboard a
device securely with pretty much a zero
touch so you don't have to ship devices
with a default username and password
right that's a huge security risk so
again the website link is WWE intel.com
slash secure device on board great
another IOT device related question
which is with IOT devices we can have
thousands deployed in the field how many
topics and subscribers can I have in my
DCP project so a great question because
again with IOT devices you tend
to work at scale right so within each
project each can contain up to 10,000
subscribers Wow and 10,000 topics so
hopefully that's enough for your for
your use and lastly how long will data
be stored and it pumps up topic
well obviously acknowledge messages will
be removed from the queue immediately
however messages will persist in that
queue for up to seven days before
they're being removed so hopefully
within that seven day window you'll be
able to take that pups of data as shown
in the presentation and move into some
sort of persistent storage solution
right like like bigquery with that oh
yeah we finished up the Q&A portion of
the presentation we'd like to thank you
on behalf of sundar Intel and Google
like to thank you for joining today's
broadcast we hope you learned a lot and
appreciate your time this morning thank
you thank you
you